now we start with the fox news alert
this busy friday news night welcome to
hannity now tonight we are at the bitter
end of what was another horrific
terrible week for the biden
administration but it's friday so you
know what that means joe biden is now
kicking back for another restful weekend
of ice cream away from the white house
now meanwhile our country is falling
apart biden's treasury secretary now
predicting uncomfortably high inflation
for at least another year
what wonderful news
so i think there's a lot of uncertainty
that is related to what's going on with
russia and ukraine
and i do think that
it's it
it's exacerbating inflation
i don't want to make a prediction uh
exactly as to what's going to happen in
the second half of the year you know
we're likely to see another year in
which 12-month inflation numbers remain
very uncomfortably high
well so much for transitory now
according to the wall street journal
inflation is the single biggest concern
for the american people it's no surprise
that nearly 60 percent of americans are
unhappy with biden's performance well no
surprise to everyone except uh our
cognitively impaired commander-in-chief
who seems to believe that his
anti-energy policies they've had nothing
to do with rising energy costs rising
inflation has nothing to do with
government spending nothing to do with
his energy and economic policies you
decide
i love you know the republic saying it's
biden's gas pipeline
by biden said he's going to stop the
keystone pipeline and i did
and that's the reason prices went up
folks let's get something straight here
the keystone pipeline was two years away
it had been two percent finished
give me a break so i'm sick of this
stuff
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true
simply is true unless you're really that
dumb joe uh because you have to be
really really dumb to believe that you
know joe biden is now i blame all of my
failures on vladimir putin biden that's
not going to fly
gas prices as every american knows were
already were already way up before putin
invaded ukraine inflation was already at
a 40-year high before vladimir invaded
ukraine and by the way the oil and gas
market that is a futures market joe and
i know that's probably a little too
complicated for you to understand
especially in your compromise cognitive
state at this point in your life but
according to alberta's premiere you know
that keystone xl pipeline
that you put the axe to it would have
been completed by today and canada would
be sending us 900 000 barrels of oil a
day we can get it done in eight months
and you won't have to be importing oil
from russia and begging some of the most
unsavory characters in the world now
with that said canada is now telling us
they can give us an extra 400 000
barrels of oil a day starting
immediately that means joe you can stop
begging opec like you have been stop
dealing with the corrupt evil iranian
muellers stop begging the murdering thug
in venezuela maduro because it's
humiliating and it's embarrassing i'd
rather get it from little justin and
canada at least they're an allied
country and they're not
not run by a murdering dictator but
want to be little dictator than justin
anyway democrats are opting for catchy
slogans instead take a look
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up i want to talk
to you a little bit about why a lot of
it has to do with vladimir
you need putin be honest with the
american people
the battle for freedom
has its cost here at home as well
people are already already feeling
putin's price hikes at the pump the
larger issue about
putin's
tax that's a that's really
putin's gas hike
that's his gas hike this so much of this
uh increase in the gas tax the gas price
started
weeks leading up to what happened there
no it's it's biden's oil tax and it's
biden's 40-year high of inflation long
before vladimir invaded ukraine
democrats out there with a little
talking point the little slogan the
little bumper sticker all their lying
won't work but that didn't stop joe
biden from tweeting that he will quote
take every step that he can to minimize
putin's price hike here at home well
it's actually the biden price hike now
it's a kind of weird thing to say since
he won't restart the keystone xl
pipeline he won't allow drilling in
amwar he won't even unfreeze
new exploration permits and he's
lecturing constantly the oil and gas
industry that are doing their very best
as a matter of fact we can't find a
single thing that biden is willing to do
back here at home to lower prices he'd
rather beg the world's dictators now
he's willing to beg every single
dictator every despot in the world who
hates the united states he wants them to
increase energy production in their
countries uh how is that any different
in terms of how it impacts the
environment
interesting question now needless to say
it's not going well gas prices inflation
was happened long before this invasion
it's going to continue to rise joe's
economic and energy policies caused it
now kamala harris was asked about this
serious economic issue she had no answer
whatsoever watch with your own eyes
president biden has said that americans
will feel some pain for the sake of
defending freedom and liberty
but there does seem to be no end game in
sight
how long should americans expect how
long should we be bracing for
this really sort of
historic inflation and some
unprecedented gas prices
in terms of
the discussions that the president
johannes and i had they ranged in
subject including the issue of the black
sea and i'll let him
explain in more detail as he would like
who's worse
is it joe or kamala that was a simple
question to ask and for the record she
never managed to answer the question i
don't know between joe and kamala harris
our country is being led by utter idiots
at this point and now the american
people were all paying the price and our
national security is compromised on top
of it joe's policies are hurting joe
abandoned energy independence joe
abandoned america as a net exporter of
energy now we're a net importer by far
now prices have been rising sharply ever
since he got into office but remember
according to joe and the democrats joe
biden has nothing to do with this
inflation that has been at a 40-year
high for months forget the trillions of
dollars in new spending the trillions in
handouts and entitlements forget the new
restrictions on oil and gas and rising
gas prices and energy prices according
to the left this is all vladimir putin's
fault because he invaded ukraine
19 days ago this week our very own peter
ducey asked circle back uh chief
propagandist jenn saki if the
administration was planning to blame
putin for everything that goes wrong in
the u.s until the midterms take a look
inflation goes up today the president's
statement blames the putin price hike
are you guys just going to start blaming
putin for everything
until the midterms well we've seen the
price of gas go up at least 75 cents
since president putin lined up troops on
the border of ukraine and and
last month the statement didn't mention
the putin price hike it mentioned
inflation because of the pandemic why is
that
well peter last year last two years
there was a global pandemic